at this stage I'd love to board a
working Taiwanese long liner to see what
they make of the murder video but they
rarely come in support Victoria and
they're not exactly keen to talk and
said I've been invited on to a local
long liner it's smaller than the
Taiwanese [ __ ] going down but catches
fish in the same way captain how are you
Oh fine thank you good very good Steve
long liners are named after the long
thin line that often stretches 60 miles
behind them there are thousands of hooks
spaced at intervals down the line
but each fish has to be reeled in by
hand one at a time a catch on these
local long liners is closely monitored
but the foreign boats seem to play by
different rules
how much control realistically do you
think the seychelles has over those
boats
do they even ever come into port
Victoria or do they just stay out there
and do what they want I believe a lot of
these boats are black and licensed
without even coding in for civilians the
observers and the ports will never know
we never know exactly you don't get
access to the logbooks to know the
movements the catch birthday hooks being
set for day and and you don't know
what's happening you hear that they are
offloading in whatever port and today
there has to be tons of illegal
activities going on
commercial fishing boats are always
meant to register their catch to check
conforms with their quotas
but by transshipping their load to
another boat they can escape detection
their catch gets mixed up with legally
caught fish and appears legitimate this
is known as fish laundering and it cost
the global economy billions of dollars a
year
our economy's our livelihoods and our
food all depend on our oceans illegal
fishing depletes the world's fisheries
or the long liners from the videos into
this sort of racket fishing illegally in
the Indian Ocean
[Music]